[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the death
eaters specifically what happened to
them after the second wizarding war
after the battle of hogwarts there was
only one thing that mattered lord
voldemort was dead and with his end the
wizarding world was finally free from
the terror that shook it to its core for
the past few decades but killing
voldemort didn't solve every problem
that harry potter and his wizarding
friends faced because there were still
plenty of death eaters alive and well
and nobody knows what exactly came of
them today we're going to take a look at
a handful of the most dangerous death
eaters from the battle of hogwarts and
try our best to figure out where they
ended up amicus caro when lord voldemort
led the coup against the ministry of
magic he used his newfound power to
install his agents in positions of power
across the wizarding world
one of these agents was amicus carro a
prominent dark wizard who had once
fought alongside the dark lord during
the first wizarding war in the late 70s
like lucius malfoy and many other death
eaters who've survived the first war
amicus didn't spend his days searching
for his master lord voldemort in defeat
instead he simply passed the years
hiding in the shadows alongside his
sister electo
it wasn't until wood voldemort regained
a proper physical body thanks to peter
pettigrew's potion that cairo came back
to the fold after which amicus rejoined
the death eaters in their reign of
terror across britain eventually
culminating in cara's appointment as
professor of defense against the dark
arts at hogwarts but in the aftermath of
the final battle there when voldemort
was killed by harry potter where did
carob end up conventional wisdom would
point to azkaban just like the death
eaters from the first wizarding war the
dark wizards from this conflict were
being sent back to that wizarding prison
to serve life sentences
but what if carol got away
amycus was born into a wealthy and high
esteemed pureblood family
if he could only put a bit of space
between himself and the ministry's auras
he surely had the means to escape if
somehow he managed to escape from
ravenclaw tower where he was tied up
during the battle of hogwarts amicus
could have slipped away never to be
heard from again
especially if he had the help of his
sister
electo carro
electocarro was amicus's sister and
shared a similar fate
just like her brother electo was one of
the most important death eaters during
voldemort's campaigns in the second
wizarding war
as the dark lord slowly eroded away the
ministry of magic's legal powers alecto
carried out missions to keep the rest of
the british wizarding world too afraid
to fight back
eventually she earned herself a
professorship at hogwarts under the
direction of its new headmaster severus
snape but after a tumultuous career
there alecto's tenure ended with the
battle of hogwarts
along with her brother she was bound in
ravenclaw tower since she didn't partake
in any of the famous showdowns in the
lower chambers of the castle
there was a small sliver of time that
alecto could have escaped with amicus at
her side it wouldn't take much for the
dark witch to navigate above the ruins
of hogwarts and find a route perhaps
they would have chartered a course to
the forbidden forest and found the train
tracks that looped around the woods
that would have put the siblings on a
path directly for voldemort's camp
though and they would have undoubtedly
joined their master in his final siege
of the grounds
but if they manage to avoid him it's
unlikely that the ministry or its auras
could have done much to prevent the
carros from living the rest of their
lives with new identities
augustus rookwood augustus rookwood was
one of voldemort's most formidable
allies and by the time of the second
wizarding war one of his oldest rookwood
served a unique role within the rank of
the death eaters he was a mole within
the ministry of magic
of course for voldemort to succeed in
his campaigns against his fellow wizards
he needed to lure many influential
ministry workers to his cause
but augustus was special because he
worked in the department of mysteries
the very place that held the secrets of
thought love time and death
the latter was a concept that voldemort
could never really grasp and by albus
damodal's own declaration
it was the one thing that voldemort
feared above all it's not hard to
imagine that augustus's position as an
unspeakable in the ministry of magic was
one of voldemort's most prized
acquisitions
and perhaps augustus's research
contributed to voldemort's own
resurrection during the battle of
hogwarts augustus met his match when he
took on albus dumbledore's younger
brother aberforth
augustus was stunned in the
confrontation and just like the carrow
siblings his story ends there most
assumed he died or was quickly ferried
off to azkaban but what if he wasn't we
already know a lot about augustus's past
as an unspeakable he had access to
ancient arcane knowledge and
cutting-edge research
besides helping voldemort get his hands
on the prophecy of harry potter augustus
as we mentioned earlier might have
learned much more
if rookwood were able to somehow avoid
the trip to azkaban he could have
slipped away just like death eater
sympathizers who continued their mundane
lives in the aftermath of the battle
but unlike those others augustus might
have continued to fight for the cause
and more continued his research
by their very nature the unspeakables
were a mystery but even though we don't
know much about their job and the unique
magical talents they possessed we can be
certain that rookwood had knowledge of
not only the death chamber but the time
chamber as well
at least during his time working at the
ministry of magic
if he managed to escape it wouldn't be
too far-fetched to imagine him alone
trying to recreate a new stock of time
turners like the ones destroyed during
the battle of the department of
mysteries if he were ever able to make
one perhaps he would have gone back in
time and prevented voldemort from
attempting to kill harry potter in the
first place
like the dark lord's own daughter delphi
would eventually do in the cursed child
fenrir greyback fenrir greyback might
seem like a run-of-the-mill death eater
but he actually wasn't he worked closely
with voldemort and his dark wizards but
fenrir actually wasn't officially part
of the crew
instead the werewolf allied himself with
voldemort because they share the common
goal
overthrowing the existing power
structure in the wizarding world
fenrir just like tom riddle had a
problem with wizards they held a
prejudice against werewolves and treated
those infected with lycanthropy as a
type of vermin that terrorized their
communities fenrir was not only offended
by that ideology but enraged and he made
it his personal goal to infect as many
wizards with lycanthropy as possible so
that he could create an army large
enough to undo the ministry of magic
but that all came to a halt during the
battle of hogwarts
there ron weasley and neville longbottom
beat fenrir and in the aftermath it's
likely that the werewolf was bound in
magical chains and escorted into a cell
in azkaban
if he wasn't killed in the battle
but what if fenrir survived too
by the end of the battle his legion of
werewolf converts would have been
decimated dumbledore's army would have
made sure of that so fenrir would need
to rebuild but he couldn't go about it
as brazenly as he had during voldemort's
rise to power
now fenrir needed to revert back to the
shadows and live his life in secrecy
if he was smart fenrir would have
afforded the entire wizarding community
altogether which meant that in order to
grow his werewolf army greyback would
need to do the very thing he despised
hunt muggles fenrir might have stayed in
england in order to achieve his goals
but with the magical community
strengthening under harry potter's
victory it would only be a matter of
time before wizards and witches started
to notice a surge in muggle-born
werewolves
if fenrir was smart then he would flee
the country and charge for a course
towards a more unstable part of the
world perhaps that would lead gray back
into the east to the rural towns that
dotted the old soviet bloc
or maybe farther to the war stricken
steps of chechnya
there fenrir could hunt to his heart's
content but unlike wizards and witches
which were his typical victims he needed
to be much more careful with muggles
without magic at their side the muggles
needed to depend on modern medicine to
heal themselves and it wasn't always up
to repairing werewolf maulings if fenrir
were able to build a true army of
werewolves with thousands and thousands
of members it's likely he would have
turned his sights back on the ministry
of magic in england
as we know his goals were aligned with
voldemort bringing about a new order
while the second wizarding war
devastated the wizarding community
perhaps fenrir's new one the werewolf
rebellion could have been even worse and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel as always leave
your video suggestions down below
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you